The problem for environmental chemicals
is that many of them have structures
that are not commonly seen in nature,
so organism simply have not had a chance to
evolve defenses against these compounds.
It may be something like 80,000
synthetic industrial compounds in the
last century
and that includes everything from
plastics to flame retardant
to pesticides that are used essentially
to deal with many of the problems that
you have in modern life
and their exceedingly complicated. You
have a very, very complex experiment in
which I love us are the subject
and many of these compounds are known to
have endocrine-disrupting activity which
means that they will behind
to are hormone receptors and
act like or Mon mimics many types as
diseases
these are things like breast cancer and
prostate
are caused by mis-regulation of our
hormone systems.
The cell is adapted to deal with
compounds in the environment.
An analogy we use is to say that cells are
a little bit like
nightclubs. What we mean by that is that
a cell really has to decide what gets in and
what doesn't
the mechanism for this is by proteins
called drug transporters
and in that analogy you can think of
these as being a bit like the bouncers
of the cell
they decide who gets and
who doesn't and their ability to
recognize a compound is very important
for determining whether a compound is
going to
accumulate or be eliminated from the
body
So in our lab what we want to do with
that big
pile of 80,000 compounds is decide which
ones
are problems and regulate them
accordingly
and have rules for designing safer
alternatives rather than simply
banning a compound we can actually
figure out whether a compound can be
redesigned or tweaked in a certain way
so that it still gives us the beneficial
properties that we want
without being as persistent and that's
going to change the face
how we do environmental chemistry. The
design of compounds that'll be
much safer